[Music]
in gender confusion news huh quite often
I don't know what that is non-binary
situations by submitted by hola TIFF
hola hola us Chinese female track
runners go viral for looking like men I
saw this [ __ ] and I was like where are
the ladies how short is the haircut it's
not even that they're Ryan's hair it's
our yeah it's not really about there
it's literally like so they have lesbian
haircut no dirt no men bodies men faces
do a hair joke here in there that's fine
from my professional diagnosis these are
[ __ ] dudes [ __ ] dudes right pretty
sure they're [ __ ] dudes Ryan goes in
he's like you'll give me the Ruby Rose
give me the scissors special it was so
funny because like when this was posted
all over you don't like a lot of the
Asian forms like next shark or whatever
right like a lot of people assume that
Asians would be outraged like oh how
could they see a man about this yes
let's see it because okay I'll tell you
the rest
yes yes cuz they don't know what you're
talking about so he's doing oh yeah
that's uh right oh Jesus this is the
women's track especially the two in the
middle yeah dudes yeah so I will show
you a video
the way she was doing it I was like
those actions are lethal Matthew was all
[ __ ] doing it so the thing is this
was all being circulated in like you
know Asian like editorials or whatever
thinking that people would back them up
like yeah this is an outrage
nobody [ __ ] back that [ __ ] up nobody
that's pretty strong metal was like are
you sorry the woman in the middle looked
I think also the lack of breasts yeah
and if your boys there are things that
you could do if you want to be seen as a
woman there are things that you could do
to really nail that look so some people
were commenting like well if they had
longer hair like some of the other bears
it's the ratio it's the squareness of
the body like you put hair that guy and
I think they have a joke like an Adam's
apple yeah and they have a jawline
that's [ __ ] stronger than my jawline
for sure she has a softer jawline out of
curiosity go structure job makes it look
like a man is this do you think this is
Custer like do you think it's the
steroids gonna I met my father
they don't a little too hard on the
steroids oh yeah because it almost looks
like the hormonal imbalance is just not
I don't know well I'm in the fitness
industry right
I'm surrounded by chicks that do
steroids right those are [ __ ] dudes
yeah because they actually got I mean so
first place and second place dumb get
this dudes and a [ __ ] female ladies
that person especially the one on the
right there in the middle on the way out
that guy if you put a long hair on this
chick or gives it sure she just looks
like a rocker like it doesn't make it
look like a woman you know I'm saying
structural mike mo from once upon a time
Hollywood you could have played Bruce
Lee Oh easily
dude Davey needs a little bit longer
here I think but yeah those two guys
look like they're from an Asian frat
like yeah I don't know if I mean this
might start a new epidemic whatever
because I'm pretty sure they're not like
checking to see if LeBron James is a
lady or like they're not pantsing people
before every single game cuz they're not
checking their gender right but I think
they need to start doing that if they're
gonna start looking like this we should
just check the ones that look the most
like it cuz you don't know if Steph
Curry is a lady and you don't know if
like some female athletes are dude you
just don't know you just take people's
word for like even when I compete as a
power lifter I just write I'm a male and
they're taking my word so the real
question here is are the two ladies
offended because that's the only people
that should be offended and how did they
took him away like that yeah that's what
that's magic all of them did by the way
the National athletics championship in
China said that they were they are woman
women they check though what's their
means of checking oh sorry the Chinese
Athletic Association confirmed their how
do they confirm trust it tell you
probably visual confirmation they're not
doing visual confirmation although there
was another woman athlete who had high
testosterone and they test her blood and
they said she had testosterone levels
that were near man wasn't Chinese though
she wasn't black but she was intimating
test they test test test roster you can
do Kings you can do blood tests too but
or if you don't want to be invasive
about it you just like check their phone
and see how many emojis they use you
don't have to be the only one way about
it but there were other people in the
comments too saying like uh China's
using men that are trying to pass off as
women why is that surprising like it's
China they're gonna cheat their way as
like whatever way they can
okay so I don't know pretty much
everyone is like putting their foot down
on I really want to see the way they
confirmed it because I am very doubtful
the funny the funny thing is though like
is people are writing this thing
thinking that a lot of people are gonna
react a certain way like oh my god how
can they ever say that about this group
and I'm just like nah man every you're
blind if you don't look at them once and
go oh wait they're groups yeah or at
least acknowledging like that's tough
meow and the other dude right the other
two on my okay your chicks yeah
but [ __ ] now dude yeah yeah their
chicks yeah that's really [ __ ] tough
you know Yang's a little in the middle
of that gang could be a like like kind
of metrosexual yeah be like a like a
Silicon Valley dude from yeah that's
true with that kind of thing but but foo
for sure that food especially hearing
food talk just sounds like a dick yeah
but Tong and Miao I don't know no that's
difficult lasses ain't helping Tom with
the femininity and that is hard but
that's that's that's what this world is
coming to they're like oh you better
check your [ __ ] stereotypical
eyeballs because you could clearly tell
they were women and in this life my
primitive [ __ ] eyeballs told me
immediately these are men yeah you can't
tell can you
I just want to know the millions of
combinations especially for them like
pregnant belly like on that frame is be
like that's really hard to like just
yeah like the best shape ever yeah I've
seen some awkwardly shaped people like
that though were they just like they
look skinny but they have a huge gut oh
yeah I mean if they say they're women
they're women right I don't know that's
not what I'm debating on Chinese either
that's true cuz they cheat like a
[ __ ] taiwan's racing team are
they i think it was a chinese
like uniform hopefully could never mind
well okay you're right i can't trust
chinese
that's so for like for doping right you
have a USANA and water and there they
before every test or testing okay like
is are these people using I think now
because there's all this ambiguity now
you probably need a test what people's
genders are kids from like the Dominican
Republic you know like there's some
baseball stars that come out of there
Danny Almonte yeah and they look like I
like against they're like you know yeah
young and yeah um enough but they look
like their cabs age yeah and it's like
holy [ __ ] well let me get tested though
why you test for age you could test for
age but well it's all like pursuit
because that was a big thing with that
age did not like yeah yeah is the
gymnastics like they were like everyone
was like looking at the Chinese team of
those like kind of young and then they
ruin Charles like no no they're 18 or
Lee no they were younger they cheated
that would rights amend that that's
where the scams the skepticism for me
it's just like ah but you've done
sketchy stuff before aren't you better
gymnastics when you're younger that's
lied that's why that's why they put that
all they had them as young American or
take these kids from like super young
ages and put them in these camps to like
train and the thing just their entire
life is the Olympics I forgot those but
there's a definite age limit early you
could have been 13 to 18 and they could
have been 12 or something
she's 15 for sure yeah and everyone's
just really like are you sure but the
only thing you have to like base it off
of is China's Records needs this know
cuz it's so [ __ ] boring they need
juicing they need anything they can I
saw a tweet that said man let's just
forget about that and give using many
drugs as you can and see what you missed
can't really do sport no extremes yes
yes doesn't do any drugs and he's able
to beat all the other people you like
wow this guy's really amazing dude you
jus what have you when you're parking
and a baseball game you're like [ __ ]
dude these guys are just so juiced this
[ __ ] could hit my windshield
the base bubbles windmark with Lauren
sent me so so we're on roids there was
no better time I don't care if I'm on
jobs I don't care what they're doing to
get them this is great but maybe they
should have a separate like an Olympic
division sweet I would love to watch you
know he's gonna kill the regular that
shit's like NFL Blitz yeah dope is
[ __ ] game because it didn't give a
[ __ ] about the rules on my boring ass
basically The Fast and the Furious made
a video game about football yeah they
were like on fire and [ __ ] that's way
better now they're like man forget logic
in gravity I want to drive this lever
Guinea through three buildings in Abu
Dhabi like yes helicopter with his bare
hands
I don't care that drill it was freaking
awesome I hold it my ex was like this
shit's unrealistic and I [ __ ] threw
her out of the theater I [ __ ] iperf
walked her out of the theater I don't
want to see realism yeah I know how what
does he Paul Walker run up a thing
that's falling down a hill and jump and
then turn into a plane they're warming
us up with Idris Elba he's like super
soldier yeah next thing you know he's
just gonna frickin have wings say I'd
watch the seal recommending Hobbes and
shot I haven't seen it yet yes they
freaking wits of Hawaii and fought with
primitive weapons I give people that gun
yeah but did that did they use accurate
physical south no exactly that's what I
want to hear the rock
remember the phosphors with a rock kata
a missile with his hand on ice and he
flexing his cash the tarmac that was
like 100 miles long when they were
flying
yes who cares about realism
[Music]
[Music]